I'm going to ask you to sort of go back,
transport yourself back in time,
about 10 years back,
I guess, when you were here.
And if there's anything interesting
you recall from the time that you
spent with us.
>> I would say that what impressed
me the most was the talent of
the students that I worked with.
The talent of the faculty that I
worked with, their passion for
the discipline of computer science for
information security in particular.
The fact that they treated me
as a professional colleague.
And really I learned as much
as I could humanly learn.
Didn't sleep much during that time.
I would encourage those listening
whether they're doing this full time or
part time at night,
just drink deeply from the well
while you have this opportunity.
And really when you're done
to understand that this
a constantly evolving space and
that you need to not stop learning.
You have to continually feed your mind
with new information, new knowledge.
>> I have advised many PhD students,
but you clearly stand out in that
one respect, the uncommon army
discipline that you brought to the
academic environment that we have here.
And I thank you for coming down today
and having this conversation with us.
You actually have a website, isn't it?
>> So my personal one is gregconti.com.
And actually that's a good point.
It's important to have, I think,
a professional presence online,
something each researcher
controls themselves.
And then my professional
website is cyber.army.mil.